for a while it seemed the British had
the whole leave or remain clash
monopolized in the news which didn't
last long though the Americans are now
somewhat piggybacking on this leave
remain rao in their own way however over
troops in Syria it is time to give our
brave warriors in Syria
a warm welcome home bring our troops
home US troops will be withdrawing from
Syria we have won against Isis Isis has
been defeated the fight against Isis and
violent extremists is not over our goals
are the same and we will maintain forces
yet the generals who are openly
grumbling about their Commander in
Chief's order seem to be missing the
point
Syria has become a hot potato in a game
being played out in the highest echelon
of power in the US and the EU the United
States will begin to hand off the fight
to our partners in the region no glory
and no media friendly war victory
potential just a burden so why not let
others do the dirty work and tweet
others and mean Europe of course
Europeans in turn say eh they're not
janitors to clean up after Washington
there is no prospect of British troops
going in to replace the American troops
living and therefore be there's no way
the US should be leaving a possible
power vacuum is the stanwood is it a
good idea of the Americans to pull out
of Syria immediately and so swiftly
doesn't it make the possibility of Iran
and Russia increasing their influence
their commerce could open it how can you
be very firm on Iran and at the same
time abandon northeastern Syria like
that when we know very well that might
end up boosting Iran's presence in the
area for me it's a mystery Washington
tosses the potato right back and ups the
stakes to not only the EU should fill
the void the u.s. leaves behind on the
ground but also take back hundreds of
nationals who once left to join ISIL a
trump emissary thought he was pretty
convincing openly scaremongering
Europe into submission 2015 uh-huh 130
people were killed in Paris 2016 86
killed in Nice 12 killed in Christmas
truck bombing in Berlin in 2017 13
killed by van in Spain so does it matter
what happens over there hell yeah it
matters he was serious it's not some
dark joke Senator Lindsey Graham spent a
whole minute meticulously going through
a list of all the horrendous terrorist
attacks that have left Europe scarred
the thought that this could have the
absolute opposite effect never crossed
his mind apparently these attacks in
Europe have everything to do with the
way that we handled the situation there
I'm not saying that this justifies this
terrorist attack on the contrary I'm
just saying that to put these attacks as
an argument to reengage militarily this
is just putting more butter on the
flames that is not going to solve the
problem the only thing that you're going
to have by more military engagement in
Syria is more terrorist attacks it's as
simple as that this whole row though
makes one truth glaringly obvious
neither Trump nor Europe each for
reasons of their own do not want to be
serious cleanup crew honor in this case
has no game so why not take credit for
all that's done and run away
you